there he is this place is great I'm a
sucker for good lunch joints
cool
um
how's the coffee because sometimes a
bistro is like this can be a little on
the weak side I'm not a coffee snob okay
fine
uh
what's the deal with your uncle I need
some good news is there any
progress yes I spoke with his assistant
his sister yeah and she said you're
definitely on his radar
I'm dying here you're giving me
assistance and radar but it's gonna take
time Marcus and he's a busy guy come on
cheer up man look you made the papers
son of a
no did you see my quote Oh
he was always available to Mentor me in
my coaching career
it's very nice
not exactly true
I know
but it could be
[Laughter]
yeah huh what nothing oh